[MUSIC PLAYING]
HOCHMAN: Hello.
Welcome, welcome.
Thank you all.
Thank you for coming
to Technology Day.
I am Ira Hochman.
I am the chair of the Technology
Day committee this year.
And first, I'd like to take
you through an honored ritual
here at Technology Day.
First, I will invite you to join
me as I remove my cell phone
and turn it off.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
First, I'd like to
thank a few people--
specifically, the
fantastic committee
of people that I had working
with me this year that
have put together
this program for you.
They're very energetic, great
ideas and a very fun bunch
to work with--
very enjoyable.
I'd also like to definitely
thank the faculty
for taking time to put
together these presentations
and for being here
today to talk to us.
I'd like to also
specifically thank
Lou Alexander of the Alumni
Association, who basically
manages the entire
process of Technology Day.
He's a great guy to work with--
definitely fun and
totally reliable.
It's great.
I'd also like to thank
the audience, all of you,
both here in the
auditorium, and today, we're
also being webcast live.
So I'd like to thank
the audience at home
or wherever you are
with your laptop who
are enjoying this today.
So I'm very excited
about today's program.
The subject is energy, which
has become a major concern
worldwide and MIT's
response to this
has been the creation
of the Energy Research
Council and subsequently,
the MIT Energy Initiative.
Today's program focus will be on
the evolution of today's energy
environment, as well
as a discussion of how
we can improve security and
effectiveness of today's energy
programs and systems.
The format is a little
different than last year.
After we have President
Hockfield's remarks,
we'll have three
faculty members speak.
Each speaker has 50 minutes--
there's about 40 minutes
for the presentation
and up to 10 minutes
for the questions.
Since that's such
a short time, I
please ask you to
present your questions
so that there is time for
answers and further questions.
[LAUGHTER]
There will not be a panel
Q&A after the talk this year.
I'd also like to mention
a recent addition
to the Technology Day program,
which are the poster sessions.
You may have noticed outside
in Kresge auditorium.
These are award-winning
student research projects.
And we'd like to also thank
Sally Susnowitz of the MIT
Public Service Center
for putting together
this offering outside.
And I would also encourage
you to enjoy a conversation
with the students behind these
projects during the break.
So with that, I would
like to introduce to you
Beth Garvin, the executive
VP, CEO of the MIT Alumni
Association.
She's been with MIT
for more than 20 years
and was named head of
the association in 2003.
Please welcome Beth Garvin.
[APPLAUSE]
GARVIN: Well, good morning.
It's my pleasure to
welcome you and to greet
so many old friends
and meet some new ones.
We're delighted to have you here
this weekend for tech reunions
and for this, our biggest alumni
event of intellectual nature.
Tech Night at the Pops
is probably our biggest
in terms of size overall, but
we really focus on something
important today.
I have the privilege of
leading your association,
and I do that very ably
supported by a couple of folks
I want to mention.
One is President Hockfield, who
has been incredibly supportive
of all of the alumni activities,
has been out to meet many
of you around the world in
the two years she's been here,
and I just cannot say enough
how important her presence is
and her participation
in all these events.
It used to be that
the president of MIT
would go to three reunion events
over the course of this very
busy weekend with commencement
and the ROTC hooding and all
the activities.
Susan likes to do
three or four a night.
So it really is an extraordinary
investment of time and energy
for which we're very grateful.
The other group, of
course, are the volunteers
who make all of these
activities possible.
We have more than an event
a day around the world.
And if you add in
the things that
are being webcast and carried
online in various ways,
there's just an enormous amount
of really wonderful stuff going
on, and that's due to
the many volunteers who
support the association, many
of whom are in this room.
And you'll see from
this program today
just how wonderful they are at
putting together these events.
And finally, I just
want to acknowledge
what has to be the
best alumni association
staff on the planet.
I appreciate how many of you
have come up and given me
compliments on their work.
They really are
extraordinarily hard working,
and we're here to
make your weekend as
enjoyable as possible.
We always encourage
feedback, though.
Don't usually have to encourage
this audience too much
to tell us what they think but
please, there are evaluations.
We're always trying to
make things even more
interesting, even more fun.
So do give us your feedback.
And I hope I get a chance to
say hello to everybody today.
Enjoy the program.
[APPLAUSE]
HOCHMAN: Thank you
very much, Beth.
So it's my great
pleasure and honor
to introduce someone you
may be familiar with,
the 16th president of MIT,
President Susan Hockfield.
[APPLAUSE]
HOCKFIELD: Good
morning, everyone.
It's not so sunny today,
but you know what?
It was sunny yesterday.
We were blessed with a
glorious day for commencement,
and we are blessed, I say, with
a fabulous program for today.
Thank you, John, for
your great introductions
and for your work pulling
today's event together.
And I want to just
use a minute to thank
Beth and her amazing team.
She talks about how I wanted
to three or four events
a night during reunion weekend.
It would be
absolutely impossible
without this crackerjack
team that actually
does create schedules
for me that I
describe as a jigsaw puzzle.
The events are knit
together like this.
So I know I saw many
of you last night
and at your fantastic events.
The mood is among you--
I think, reflects
the mood on campus,
which is optimistic, ebullient.
I'm very much excited
about what MIT
is doing on campus
and frankly, what
we contribute to the world.
Tech Day is always one
of the highlights for me
and partly because I get
to see so many of you
but also because we get to
hear from MIT's faculty leaders
about the work
that they're doing
and how the Institute
addresses the pressing
challenges of the world.
Today, we're going to focus
on what many people consider--
and I'm among them--
perhaps the world's greatest
challenge right now.
It's a challenge-- energy,
sustainable energy,
how we can use it without using
up our important resources.
Those resources include the
capacity of the atmosphere
to take up CO2.
It's also an area
where we believe MIT
can make unique contributions.
Now while I'm going to provide
a little bit of an introduction
to the energy talks that
you're going to be hearing,
we will have Q&A at the end.
And I welcome
questions on any topic.
Now, interestingly
enough, the best way
to think about
MIT's work on energy
is to begin not here in
Cambridge, but in Switzerland
at this year's World Economic
Forum in Davos last January.
At Davos this year, we had
a very strong MIT presence.
We had more than a dozen faculty
members who accompanied me.
Over the course of
several days, we
had 17 faculty presentations
at the World Economic Forum.
And there were several MIT
events in Zurich and at Davos,
including a dinner that we
hosted on disruptive energy
technologies.
We were agreed with
enormous enthusiasm,
and rather than brag
about it myself,
I thought I'd just read from you
from what the Time Magazine's
Davos correspondent wrote.
At a certain point during this
year's World Economic Forum
annual meeting in Davos,
the gusts of self-regard
became a little
too much to bear.
I found myself wondering whether
any of this high minded talk
was worth a dime.
Fortunately, that's when
something came along
to remind me of what
Davos is good for.
My breakthrough
session turned out
to be a guided tour
of the future--
MIT's dinner session on
disruptive energy technologies.
Now at the dinner we had
three of our faculty speak.
Angie Belcher talked
about the viruses
that she's persuaded
to make batteries.
Vladimir Bulovic talked about
solar photovoltaics and quantum
dots.
Greg Stephanopoulos talked about
a very large and fascinating
biofuels project.
And Tom Friedman who you know
from his work for the New York
Times was our introducer and
moderated the discussion.
Back to Time Magazine-- no
wonder MIT President Susan
Hockfield, seeing those sorts
of discoveries taking place
in nooks and crannies all around
her Cambridge campus decided
to gather scientists into
an Energy Research Council
and declare war on
the energy crisis,
accelerating the switch
to clean, efficient fuels.
Solving this crisis,
as Hockfield told us
as candles flickered in the
little stone grotto in Davos,
will take not one solution,
but a portfolio of solutions.
It's a sprint and a marathon.
Learning what her
scientists are up to
made me feel better about
our chances in this race.
And that's what
Davos is good for--
helping of authentic
reality-based
hope right when you
need it the most.
And that is where I begin
what MIT is good for--
a dose of authentic
reality-based
hope that we can help
address in a real way
the most serious of the
world's great challenges.
Now I'm sure I don't
need to rehearse
for this audience what actually
frames our global energy
challenge.
There is accelerating demand.
China alone is increasing
its energy use by 10% a year.
The world over is on track to
double our energy use by 2050.
The security of our
sources of energy
are historical
sources of energy are,
shall we say, not so stable.
Increasingly, those
energy sources--
the energy there itself, oil--
is in the hands of companies
that are controlled by states.
Those states are,
shall we say, can't
be relied upon to be the
most friendly to our country.
And then the
environmental implications
of our current technology--
people may argue about the cause
of about whether the increased
CO2 in the atmosphere is
the cause of global warming.
I personally believe what the
preponderance of scientists
say about this.
But if you look at the
concentration of CO2
in the atmosphere, that was
about 280 parts per million
in 1900.
It is 380 parts
per million today.
It is rising at a rate that
is absolutely unsustainable.
Whether that is the cause
of global warming or no,
we are using up a
limited resource,
and that limited
resource is the capacity
of our atmosphere to hold CO2
in a way that is sustainable.
It's consistent with life as
we know it on this planet.
MIT's response to
this energy challenge
is the MIT Energy Initiative.
The initiative grew
out of interest
I heard from faculty,
students, staff, and alumni
as I was learning about
the MIT community.
When I asked our
community, what are
MIT's responsibilities
and opportunities
over the next decade or two?
There was an
overwhelming call for MIT
to do more to help solve
this global crisis.
The Energy Research
Council released its report
after a year of study
just about a year ago.
It was released concurrent
with an Institute-wide energy
forum that was about the
busiest week of the year.
We held it in Kresge.
Kresge was packed.
This past fall, we announced the
formal begin of the MIT Energy
Initiative.
The initiative is
headed by Ernie Moniz
with the deputy
director Barb Armstrong.
One of the most exciting things
about MIT's Energy Initiative
is not the huge number of people
who have begun to participate,
but the fact that people
are participating in this
from all five of our schools.
The Energy Initiative has
drawn out three main themes.
The first is new technologies
for a cleaner future,
and there, we're focusing
on solar, on biofuels,
and on energy storage.
The second theme is improving
today's energy systems
for changes in the near
term, and there we're
focusing on nuclear, clean
carbon, and carbon dioxide
capture and sequestration.
The third theme is addressing
the challenges posed
by the emerging economies.
And there we feel we can
be particularly helpful
in the areas of transportation,
and construction.
And our three faculty
speakers today
will lead you through a few--
let's just say three of the
very many important strands that
comprise the Energy Initiative.
As I said, an important aspect
of the Energy Initiative
is that it reaches across
all of the schools.
Every theme, every
research direction
requires collaboration from
many different departments
in many different schools.
Each research area that I
hear described by the Energy
Initiative participants
is not an area
that could be addressed by
one faculty member or one
department or one school.
Each requires
participation across MIT,
and each also requires
not simply new technology
or new science.
Each requires technology
and policy working together.
The Energy Initiative is
not just about research.
Importantly, it's
also about education.
There is enormous student
enthusiasm and interest,
and one of the first activities
of the Energy Initiative
was to put together a
task force on education.
We have a marvelous committee
that's addressing that,
and we now have a website
that presents to our students
the range of energy-related
courses available on campus.
And the student
interest, as I said,
has just been overwhelming.
It's also important for MIT
to, what we say, walk the talk.
So one of the initiatives
first task force
is a task force on
campus sustainability
to use our campus as a
living laboratory, so we
can do what we're talking
about and what we're urging
the rest of the world to do.
The most important message
emerging out of our work
is that we have to develop
a portfolio of solutions.
There is not a
single silver bullet.
We can't focus on one
solution to address it.
We have to at the same time
pursue many different avenues.
When I first heard about
the energy challenge,
I thought about
it as a challenge
and you know with
all seriousness
about wearing extra sweaters
and turning down the thermostat.
And it seemed like, boy, it
was kind of a sorry thing.
After talking to our faculty
being in my own energy course
from our faculty and students
over the last two years,
I now see this as a fantastic
opportunity-- an opportunity
not just for a campus, but an
opportunity for the nation.
It's an opportunity to inspire
the young people of the nation
around a bright future
that they can help invent.
I see this as a
possibility of having
the same kind of catalytic
and inspirational effect
that the Apollo program
had on my generation.
The other great opportunity
is the possibility
that new energy
technology will fuel
the next cycle of the
innovation economy
that has made this
nation so strong.
We see that around here
where energy startups
and actually, large
energy companies
are moving into MIT's backyard.
It resembles, in many ways, the
beginning of the life science
revolution and the
marvelous life science
companies that have come
out of places like MIT
around the world.
Now, of course, energy
is not the only way
in which MIT's faculty,
students, and staff are working
together to address the
world's most critical needs,
and we could have picked any
one of a number of topics
to present to you today.
But I would say,
overall, there is
a huge sense of
optimism and opportunity
on campus about what
MIT is good for--
a dose of authentic
reality-based
hope that we can
contribute to solving
the world's great challenges.
In this role, MIT has been
for decades and decades
a real beacon for the world.
Now thanks to an
extraordinarily generous alumnus
who is inspired by
the idea of taking
the basket off this beacon,
off the lamp, tonight,
we're going to celebrate
a symbolic way of taking
the basket off the lamp.
And we will reignite one of my
team's most powerful symbols.
After sunset tonight,
which occurs late
because we are near the
longest day of the year,
for the first time in
more than three decades,
we will fully relight
the great dome.
The relighting is possible
because of advances
in energy-saving
lighting technologies.
The power consumption of
our new lighting techniques
is going to consume
energy that's
equal to two hair
dryers, or I've
been told the amount of energy
that's currently is consumed
by lighting in my office.
We've got to get to work on
the lighting in my office.
So the lighting itself is
very low energy consuming.
But in addition to that, again,
because of the generosity
of this alumnus who has
insisted on remaining anonymous,
we are also going
to be installing
40-kilowatt photovoltaic
cell, actually,
which greatly exceeds the call
on energy by the dome lighting.
But we see this dome
lighting as a way
to walk the talk times two.
The first is demonstrating
energy efficient lighting.
We don't have to give up a
lot of the wonderful things
we enjoy.
We just have to do things in
a more energy-efficient way.
And the second really important
part of MIT's contributions
is inspiring.
The nation the world about
the wonderful promise
of a brighter future for all
through Science and Technology.
Let me just close by
echoing some of the things
that Beth said
when she introduced
the sessions morning.
I cannot overestimate
the importance of alumni
engagement.
Of course, you should
go without saying
that your generous financial
support is essential for us
to be able to do the kind
of extraordinary frontier
advancing work that
we do and to bring
the most able and ambitious
students in the world
to this campus.
And I'm going to thank
you a little bit more
in that domain at lunch.
But for now, I really
want to thank you
for the very many other roles
you play as members of the MIT
community.
One especially critical role
is as ambassadors from MIT
to the world.
And I very much
hope that all of you
will continue to spread the
good news of MIT's contributions
to solving the world's
great challenges
and how we educate
young people from MIT
to be the people who engineer,
who develop the science, who
understand the
policy of bringing
those solutions to bear
on these great challenges.
Thank you very much for joining
us for this reunion weekend.
Let me stop there and
take a few questions
before we move on to our
faculty presentations.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions from
the floor before we--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HOCKFIELD: Yes, there are mics.
Oh, you're up there.
Okay, so you'll have to
speak very loudly, please.
AUDIENCE: Obviously, [INAUDIBLE]
HOCKFIELD: Yeah so
the question is,
it's obvious that MIT can make
major contributions in science
and technology.
But are we also working on
the policy, the economic piece
of the puzzle?
And indeed, we are.
The Energy Council, which
is the five faculty who
are primary advisors
to Ernie Moniz and
Bob Armstrong come
from each of the five schools.
And we have a number of
faculty in humanities, arts,
and social sciences
and MIT Sloan who
are actually very interested in
these policy, economic issues.
And I think you'll be hearing
a little bit about some
of that today looking at Nazli.
And she's not nodding.
We're going to hear a little bit
about some of their policy work
today.
And we actually feel that
for a couple of reasons
that MIT can knit the science
and technology together
with the policy in
almost unique ways,
partly because we have
people on campus who
are working on both
sides of that equation,
but also because MIT has
an almost unique practice
of faculty working across
what in other places
are departmental and
school boundaries.
As I think about--
at least the parts of
MIT's history that I know--
what I always think
about is the study
that led to the book Made in
America that was brought forth
during the Japanese threat
on the American economy.
Made in America was
done by a group called
the industrial
Performance Center,
which is a group of
economists, people
from MIT Sloan,
engineers and scientists.
That group continues to produce
a bunch of a number of books
and actually their most
recent book out of that group.
The main author
is Suzanne Berger.
It's a book called
How We Compete,
and it's exactly just
exactly what you asked.
It's a study of
economics and business
practices in the context of
globally successful businesses.
So indeed, the short
answer I should've said
is, yes, we are going
to be we are doing
both the economics
and the technology
around the energy challenges.
Other questions?
You'll have to actually speak
up because it's hard for me
to see if there's
anyone at a microphone.
If not, we will
proceed with the--
oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HOCKFIELD: What can we do
to persuade our government
leaders that we need programs
like Apollo in this area?
Well, I think we all can
lend our voice to that call.
Like MIT presidents
before me, I spend a day
every four to six
weeks in Washington,
working to persuade them
actually on these issues.
I spent time in Congress
at the White House
with the heads of
the various agencies
actually making this call.
And I think we
need to as a nation
articulate our interest in a
very loud way on our belief
that the energy
challenge could represent
the kind of issue to which
the nation as a whole
could direct its interest,
its enthusiasm, its ambitions.
So as I said, you are very
important as MIT ambassadors
to the world.
If you all lend your
voice to this possibility,
it will amplify the things that
I can do in person 120,000-fold
I think is a number of
our alumni right now.
Anything else?
Well, again, thank you very much
for joining us for Tech Day.
Thanks for coming
back to campus,
I hope you like what you see.
And as Beth said, this
is not a shy group.
We look forward to hearing
from you about your reflections
on this week on campus.
Welcome to MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
HOCHMAN: Thank you,
President Hockfield,
for those very interesting
information, particularly
hearing about the exciting
research and implementation
going on at MIT transporting
us to Switzerland
and also for sending us
on edge for the words
of our next speaker.
There are detailed biographies
of the speakers in your program
books, but I would
like to highlight
some facets of our next speaker,
Professor Nazli Choucri.
In addition to being a professor
at MIT's political science
department, she
is also associated
director of the technology
and development program
and head of the Middle
East program at MIT.
Professor Choucri's
primary research focus
is in international relations
and international political
economy with a special focus
on conflict, connectivity,
and the global environment.
This puts her in a particularly
advantageous perspective
to comment on the
broader context
of the energy challenges we
now face-- political, economic,
and strategic, as well as
the types of coordination
that the major
nations of the world
will need to develop to
ensure our energy future.
I'd also like to mention
that there are microphones
located in the aisles.
If you have
questions, please feel
free to line up at
the microphones.
So please join me in welcoming
Professor Nazli Choucri.
[APPLAUSE]
CHOUCRI: Thank you,
Ira, for this very
gracious introduction.
I'm going to ask you to
work with me as we place
energy in a global context.
And part of what I will
say will not seem obvious
as to what the energy
connections are,
and this is where
your homework comes
in helping me out on this.
So am I doing this right.
Hmm.
This is not my machine.
I have no clue how
this thing works.
Okay we'll try again.
Ah, it's this way?
HOCHMAN: It's it right here.
CHOUCRI: Yeah.
Good.
This is the social sciences.
I'm going to be talking
about three issues,
and each one of them is
really quite important.
The first is to take stock of
the legacy of the 20th century.
What is it that we're
carrying with us today?
The second is to look at
the global system as a whole
and in what I will refer to as
some odd views of the system
and finally, some political
realities for energy
in the 21st century.
So we'll take those
one at a time.
On the legacies, I've chosen
to focus on four core ones
and then look at some
of the surprises--
the good news, the bad news,
and the unexpected from which I
will ask.
So I will propose
the balance sheet.
What do we have?
What do we get out of this?
What are the net effects?
So on the legacies, the
ones that I have chosen
are self-evident, but there are
surprises in each one of them.
The first is
population dynamics,
and we're all familiar with
the rabbit population growth
almost in one word.
Then the issue of
some issues related
to technology and
implications for energy use.
Some energy basics in the
really most basic sense
is seen from a
political scientist.
And then a reminder, the fourth
legacy is a reminder of the new
global agenda-- the new
global political agenda--
the world out there that
is changing, perhaps
far more rapidly than we
are able to understand
or accommodate it.
So one legacy at a time--
on population dynamics,
we all know that there
are more people on this planet.
We also know that there's some
important demographic shifts.
We're not exactly sure
what the shifts are
or how important they are,
but we know they're out there.
And then finally, the
biggest legacy we have
of the 20th century is the
matter of crossing borders.
Just about everybody
on this planet
is on the move for
one reason or another.
And every move is related to
some increment of energy use.
The statistics that
we have about mobility
of people and the venues and
the duration and the location
and the sources and
the consequences
are not quite synchronized
with the knowledge
that we need with respect to
the associated energy uses.
So first, the familiar which
is more people on this planet
that I don't need to say
anything more about it.
The insert here is perhaps
a little less familiar,
and this is, believe
it or not, there
has been a slight improvement
in the human condition
since over the past
century or so in the sense
that the share of the
poor has declined.
Now you may consider
that good news,
but placed in the
context of the demands
and the needs of the poor
population, that's not
as good news as we would want.
And then let's factor in
the energy requirements
almost by necessity, as we
all become wealthier, richer,
better off, and so forth.
And here's a minor footnote--
the individual-- Joe Smith,
let's say, John Doe--
living in China is embedded
in an energy infrastructure
that is quite different.
So his own individualized
per capita consumption
is very different than if Joe
Smith or John Doe, whoever
it is moves to Los Angeles.
And the same individual, nothing
is strange about him or her--
simply the infrastructure within
which he works has changed.
And there the energy numbers
look quite different.
As a simple reminder as to
the mobility of people--
now this is very misleading
because I should give you
the other side of it, which
I'm not going to give you--
and that is the
percentage of the migrants
to the total population,
which is not in this case.
The only thing I want to
draw your attention to
is that movement across
borders generating
a stock measured at one point
in time is very, very large.
And the word migrant here
refers to a voluntary movement--
people who willingly
decide to cross borders.
Most people, let me
put it differently.
That's a large
fraction of crossing
borders that is not voluntary.
That too carries with it some
energy-related coefficients,
leaving aside the coefficients
related to justice,
quality of life, et cetera.
So what I've covered so far
are related to basic facts.
Let's talk about some surprises.
And this is where I ask you
to consider the implications.
The first surprise has to do
with the unexpected, declines
in fertility.
We had never thought 50
years ago, 60 years ago,
30 years ago--
over 30 years ago when I joined
the MIT faculty that we would
consider this an issue decline.
And I'll get to do that
in more that in a minute.
The second surprise is the
dependency ratio in population.
And then finally,
the aging society--
the aging society
is a correlate.
It is connected
to, tightly coupled
tightly with the
industrializing society.
So the question
to you is the quiz
for this morning is, do you
see any energy-related impacts
either on the demand side
or on the distribution
side or other infrastructure
requirements side,
or is this just a blip
in our statistics?
And hey, life is complicated.
So let's look at the
fertility declines.
What you see here is a fairly
good representation of what
we now understand
to be a basic fact,
and this is in
industrialized countries,
the populations are not
reproducing themselves.
Now we consider that a problem.
One could consider
that a problem.
In the old days, the only
problem we're familiar with
is rapid population growth.
Too many people are
having too many children.
And I'm not passing
judgment here.
I'm simply saying that
this is a surprise
because we had not expected it.
We had not looked for it.
We had not anticipated it.
And this comes from
the economists.
And I just love this one
for the following reasons.
There were plenty of clues
before the popular press
picked up the fact that the
Russians were disappearing.
And here it has to do
mainly with the fertility
side that the death rate and
the life expectancy of Russian--
then the Soviet
population-- was going down,
having to do with
health-related issues,
having to do with inhaling
too many stuff that's
not good for you, et cetera.
And we saw that long
before were able to connect
energy, climate change
potentials, pollution,
and health--
pieces that we now take for
granted as going together.
This is not very good news
for the Russians-- at least
I don't think it's
good news for them.
And the standard
policy that countries
have when faced with news
that they don't consider good
is to try to do something.
And we know based on the history
of the advanced industrial
countries that it
is any policy to try
to increase the fertility rate.
And an advanced
industrial country
is doomed to failure--
has failed to no end.
Case in point here
would be France.
This is probably more than
you really want to know,
but it's not connecting
much more closely
to the energy issue.
And I just want to
draw your attention
to the solid black line, which
is the rising dependency ratio,
which is the ratio of the
non-working population
to the working population.
And we really don't want to
have this dependency ratio go up
because it means that the
working population has
to support a larger fraction
of the total population.
So on the quiz sheet
for this morning
is, is this trend that we
now think is fairly robust--
is it neutral with respect to
energy effects on any dimension
of the energy issue?
Now we move on to
the technology parts.
And in this audience,
I will not presume
to say anything technical
on the technology aspect.
But I will focus specifically
on three issues that
are fundamentally important
legacies of the 20th century
and are going to face
shape how we deal
with the 21st century
on energy issues
and just about everything
else under the sun.
The first is globalization and
the persistence of this thing
that we call globalization.
We did the rough census of
what globalization means,
and I won't bore you with
varieties of definitions
that we came up with
in the literature
and in the popular press.
But the fact is everything
is crossing borders,
whether it's people, ideas,
things, and so forth.
The second issue
is globalization.
And no, I did not
make this word up.
This comes from the
United Nations' coining
of this concept to reflect the
conjunction of globalization
processes but the localization
effects of globalization--
so the linkages between
globalization and localization.
The interesting thing
here is that we now
know that are many local
effects that have been generated
by the globalization process.
So it's not a decoupling.
It's a recoupling
in a different way.
What we don't yet know is
how we can connect this fact,
I would say, to our energy
policies, our energy
strategies, and of course, to
the application of innovation
in this area.
So consider this the
next item on the quiz.
The third energy issue that
is very, very important
goes without saying is the
global race for knowledge.
It's not the global arms
race of the olden days.
But it is a race, nonetheless.
And what I will
draw your attention
to in just in just a
minute is the impact
of this race on one particular
domain, and that is the shifts.
What has this done to shift
the way in which we organize
and think about our
social activities
and about where value added
is or added value is--
sources of added value?
There are multiple
indicators of globalization.
I don't need to persuade you
that there is something going
on out there in the world.
At the simplest, a
trend I could get around
which there would be no
controversy more or less
is world trade.
So take that as an indicator.
Most interesting,
however, is the impact
of knowledge and density--
the impact of shifting
this structure of economies
and the structure of societies.
And we're moving
in that direction.
And as we go down that path,
what implications are there
for energy?
I would like to think that
it's got to be only good news,
but I'm an optimist.
So what we've already
started to see
as a legacy from
the 20th century
is a gradual shift from the
strict thinking about supply
chain requirements as
being anchors of meeting
supply chain requirements
as being anchors
due to the economy and to
the social order to thinking
about the knowledge chain.
And what we're
doing here at MIT is
beginning to
formalize and clarify
what would be meant
by the knowledge chain
and at which point societies
gain by reducing disconnects
among various links
to that chain.
We've also seen shifts
from material output that
wish to have expanded
material output to the wish
to have better ways of
meeting social needs.
We're seeing shifts from
knowledge access reducing
barriers to access to
enhancing, facilitating
venues for knowledge generation
and knowledge creation.
So we're beginning to
think of knowledge not
as the residual in the
proverbial textbook
case of the production
function in the old days,
but as really endogenizing
the entire process.
And then the final shift that
is the most fabulous of all
at this point in time-- and
it was alluded to earlier
by President Hockfield--
is that the interest
that we have in contributing
to the diffusion
and the distribution
of knowledge.
Now this sounds very much like
motherhood and an apple pie,
and I certainly don't
mean to sound that way.
What I do want to say is that if
we can understand and unbundle
the knowledge chain and if we
can locate the value of doing
this with respect to our energy
dilemmas, challenges, problems,
we might be one step ahead in
framing our response policies.
Surprises-- what
are the surprises
from a socioeconomic and
political point of view.
And to me, the most
obvious surprise
of all, looking back
at the 20th century
and if we were anticipating
technological changes
would have been very difficult
then at the beginning
of the 20th century to
have correctly anticipating
the forging of virtual space--
cyberspace, the
internet, et cetera.
To the architects of
this space, the focus
has been on the
internet and the wires
and whatever else
goes into this thing.
But for the social
scientists and for the users
is the creation
forging of new spaces,
new arenas of interactions
and new voicing
and new opportunities and
again, connect new voicing
and new opportunities to
who is doing the voicing
and who is doing the
opportunities and what
difference it might make.
The last piece-- the
last mile, if you wish--
is the wireless
connections as part
of this bundle of surprises.
I'll get to that in
just a moment too.
The second surprise
is that environment
does, in fact, matter.
It's not something that we
would have anticipated early
in the 20th century.
And then the third
surprise is the dark side--
that states are at
risk from factors
that we did not expect
them to be at risk from.
So what now who or what next?
Opportunities-- this is
an example of internet
generated revenues.
I don't have the sources
here for which I apologize,
but it comes from
an economist report.
And the amount in the axis is
in the Bs, of course, so more.
With more comes more
regulatory stuff.
As a political scientist,
I take it for granted
that any new activity creates
a new bureaucracy of some sort.
Now that is not
really good news.
It may be necessary, but
it's not really good news
because we know that major,
major, major disconnects
in just basic communication
among bureaucracies
and among agencies who have the
same mission statement create.
We're creating a
headache for ourselves
that we may not
necessarily want to.
Another part of the
technological surprise-- and I
put it on the side
of technology here
as opposed to on the side of the
ledger of the social scientists
who could have tried a little
harder to anticipate some
of those differences-- there
are two pieces of the surprises
that are important in terms
of the environmental effects
of our industrialization
trajectory.
One is the differential impacts
across and within countries,
which you know.
But second is that there
are going to be already
but will continue
to be more burdens
on the poor everywhere
in all societies,
this society as well.
Does energy policy
factor into this at all?
By now, you may think that
the connection between energy
and the issues that I'm
raising is far too long.
The chain there is too long.
But let me assure
that it really is not
if you consider it
carefully because we're also
seeing, anticipating
the prospects of more
social cleavages as potential
effects of climate change
arise.
The next item on this
checklist is the erosion
of the power of governance
and the power of institutions
if they get overloaded by the
effects of the transformations
in the natural environment.
Without spending too
much time on this,
the other side of the
loss of law and order
is the growth in individual
entrepreneurship-- self-help,
if you wish.
And remember societies
are organized
to prevent excessive self-help.
So what we worry about
here is that we have not
thought enough about the
potential consequences
on the social order of
this particular surprise.
And now we understand that
this is terrifically important
and where are-- the at least
in the [INAUDIBLE] science
department--
spending serious time
looking at that issue.
There is some attempt to measure
the international impacts
of potential climate change.
If you notice a highlight
potential just in case
the controversy
is on this issue.
And the climate change
index is now considered
as plausibly accurate with
respect to countries at risk--
at risk with respect
to health hazards,
physical, and
physical conditions
as well as immediate
environmental impact
or environmental dislocation.
This is not really
very good news.
But I think that as we think
about the energy, climate
or energy environment
linkages, we're
going to have to
recognize that there
are significant high
probability outcomes
that we're going to have to
deal with somewhat seriously.
And I identified sharing
with you two of those here.
The first bullet is
respective 10 countries
that are high in
terms of overall risk,
and you have the list
of the countries here.
But these are
countries that so far
account for a very small amount
of greenhouse gas emissions.
Some of these
countries will be going
under reconstruction programs.
And so the challenge
is how can we
best engage in reconstruction
without putting in place
the energy economy
interactions that
were destroyed to begin with?
And President Hockfield
referred to efficiencies
on the MIT campus.
Can efficiencies
be imposed upon,
transferred portable to
large-scale reconstruction
efforts.
We hope so, but
the records so far
in terms of the reconstruction
of destroyed economies
over the last decade
or so shows us
that we are very good
at reconstructing
what we've already destroyed.
We're not good at
putting in place
the new generations of
technologies that are already
available to us.
Okay, this is a simple
reminder of the distribution
of who's going to be
in pain on this one
and without any statement
about the nature of the pain.
And now I get to
the darker side--
the countries at risk--
at risk of conflict
or at risk of being
the recipient of
unhappiness that
is generated
elsewhere associated
with climate-related issues.
There is a concentration,
as you can see,
in the African continent.
There are also a bunch
of other concentrations.
The interesting thing about this
is that this assessment comes
out of the community
that focuses
on climate-related
impacts, and the fact
that they're concerned with
conflict at exactly the time
in which the political conflict
community in political science
is beginning to think about
the environmental effect
is an example of
the type of coupling
that we've started to
do and we're getting
to be much more involved with.
And let me stress
the obvious by way
of indicating how important
this is, the coupling part,
and that is the social
sciences as all of the sciences
but only with the social
sciences were framed
and developed over time
by very carefully carving
out, partitioning human activity
out of the natural environment
and looking at the space and
then very carefully cutting out
pieces of human activity.
So you have the politics for the
political scientists, economics
for the economists, and so forth
knowing that the world is not
that way, but understanding
that this is how we
will generate knowledge faster.
Now we realize that
the strategy that
has been very successful
throughout the 20th century
and before is a major
liability today.
So now what we're
trying to do is
put Humpty Dumpty together
again but in a way that does not
undermine the growth
and the strength
of the individual disciplines
and in the individual fields.
Needless to say, this is
easier said than done.
But the more important and
the more serious part of this
is that the need
to reconnect is one
that comes from within
the fields, so there's
a very powerful
realization that we
have to reshape our system
boundaries and our field
boundaries.
Now the issue of energy basics,
the third set of legacies.
Fossil fuels, the usual--
I don't need to
review that with you.
The second legacy has
to do with the continued
politicization of energy.
Energy, as you know, is
intensely political issues
across the globe--
maybe with the exception
of legislation budgets.
There's a search
for alternatives--
the usual, maybe
more than usual.
But then we have the mess
in the Middle East, which
is clearly more than the usual.
When you put all
these things together,
we have some immediate
short-term dilemmas.
We won't call them crises.
And Professor Deutsch may
address those in a few minutes.
But what I'd like to
do is share with you
the view that the usual
is a bit more messy
than it has been in the past.
This is a simple reminder
of the flow of exports
of oil and global oil.
I just picked this one
up because the message
is very, very clear.
And you see the salience and the
centrality of the Middle East
and followed by a vision from
The Boston Globe in 1986.
This actually is very accurate.
'86 is decades ago.
I mean, you're
familiar with this,
but there is, unfortunately,
one more angle on that,
which is this way.
The message here may not
be what you think it is.
It has to do with in addition
to this mess, we have a mess
where the many, many players--
not all of which are controlled
by states, and not all of which
define winning and
losing the same way.
This is the complexity
of the Middle East.
The good news is that this
particular cartoon is not
about a major oil-producing or
natural gas producing region.
It is differences of perspective
over a non-oil-producing area.
So if we take this
cartoon and put it
on the future of Saudi
Arabia or the future of Iran
or the future of you name
your favorite oil producer,
we have a slightly
complicated situation
that's going to create
imperatives for us right now.
This is one of the most powerful
legacies of the 20th century.
Just to show you that I'm
able to be even-handed on this
comes from Time Magazine.
You may not be able to see it.
So I'll tell you why
this is interesting.
It is a set of instances
in which the good guys--
by the good guys, I mean
countries like Norway--
begin to do some rather
unpleasant things
over resource-related matters
and energy-related matters.
And the case in
which the clashes--
this is a case of Japan
between Japanese fishermen
and the Russian Navy.
And then we have the Chinese
and [INAUDIBLE] this right--
oh, sorry, shouldn't
touch this stuff--
help.
Can somebody come?
[APPLAUSE]
I'm sorry.
I'm not going to be
embarrassed, so don't try.
Okay, eventually, you can
get the hard copy of this.
I apologize because
it's not very clear.
But the Russians tried
to pressure the Georgians
by boycotting their wine
and their mineral water
over some dispute, and
that had some connections
to the pricing of imports
and exports of commodities.
Now the surprise in the
energy from the social science
point of view.
First, we hadn't expected the
breakdown of the Soviet Union.
It came too quick, too
fast, and too thorough.
But what it did do
is shift control
over known energy resources.
The new state owners
have new priorities.
And most of the time,
we're not exactly
sure what their priorities are,
so the uncertainties for us
go up.
And I do want to talk
about security issues.
This is just legacies.
And the bottom line of this on
the political economy of energy
that's been handed to
us from the 20th century
is uncertainties about
who controls what
in the shorter time horizon.
Now to the fourth and
last part of the legacy
of the 20th century.
I've picked up what
I believe to be
the ones that will
remain powerful
throughout the 21st century.
The salience of environment
is very, very, very unlikely
that this is an issue
that will go away
unless we become unbelievably
creative more than we
can imagine.
The evidence that we have
so far-- and regretfully,
I don't have that on
the slide for you--
is the enormous growth of
international environmental
treaties--
multilateral treaties.
This is not treaties
that contain
an environmental
component clause in it,
but focusing specifically
on environment.
And the most interesting
thing about that
is that the trend of global
environmental treaty-making
looks exactly the same as
the trend of US participation
environmental treaty-making.
So all things
considered, what we've
gotten from the 20th century is
a very high participation rate
by the United States.
The second major issue
on the global agenda
that is clearly
new is the issue of
sustainability and
sustainable development.
And now when you
drill into the issue,
we come up against
sustainability, sustainable
energy as strategies for the
sustainableness of energy
issues.
That, of course, is part of
the research agenda here.
The next item that is part
of the global agenda--
and by global agenda, I mean the
global political agenda and its
connections to our
own research agenda--
is getting a better
handle on the not
so much the sources of
potentials for climate change.
This is fairly well understood.
What is not understood is the
nature of the consequences
once you get beyond
the general averages
or the general statements,
particularly those consequences
for which it is possible to
intervene today effectively
piece of an important
research agenda.
The fourth item on the new
global agenda for politics
and the world and
for the academy
is revisiting the fundamentals.
The fundamentals and
economic performance
and economic growth in the past
has always been efficiency.
Efficiency is really important.
Now we factor in looking for
the possibility of coupling
efficiency and equity.
Can it be done?
We are assuming
that it can be done.
So the pursuit of efficiency
in economic activity,
in policy but constraining
that in some fashion
with a serious
attention to equity--
equity measures of equity.
And this then leads
us to the final item
on the new global agenda that
I would like to share with you,
and that is there is a trend out
there in the political world,
in the UN world seeking to
define global public goods.
And at academy, were trying to
articulate how one can actually
think about funding money,
articulating funding
and implementing any notion
of global public goods.
This is more than international.
This is more than transnational.
This is addressing the
nature and the composition
of the responsibility that civil
society at the global level
has to itself.
So the dangers on the
environment side--
we've gone through this before.
But I do want to draw
your attention to the very
last item on that, and that is
matters related infrastructure.
It goes without
saying that most of us
believe that if there is serious
potential of climate change,
if there is sea level
rise, et cetera, et cetera,
the odds are very, very
high that our physical
infrastructures are going to
be affected very, very deeply
seriously.
So what do we do?
Balance sheet now on the
legacies of the 20th century--
the good news and the bad news.
The good news that we are going
to be calling the three Es
is coupled with some bad
news that we're going
to call the missing piece.
The three Es is we
understand some,
but we understand the need
for better understanding
the interconnections
between energy, environment,
and economy.
That's a message
that we all have,
and it's reflected in our
course offerings as well.
That's the good news.
Now the missing
piece or the bad news
is that what we are ignoring
some important political
realities because politics
is uncomfortable business,
and we don't like to deal
with this unless we have to
for professional reasons.
And that is the reality
is our participation.
Remember the internet and
the virtual spaces-- more
people, more demands,
more noises, et cetera.
Power and power differentials--
who's going to be at the table
once we think about the new
energy management regimes?
The Kyoto Protocol is
up for reconsideration
I guess in six years or so.
Well, who's going to be
sitting at that table other
than countries?
And then finally, the
issue of politics--
we talk about energy policy.
We do research on energy policy.
We're beginning to think
about the politics associated
with getting the legislature
to understand that these are
important issues
or getting the EU
or getting the
German chancellor who
has been very successful
in the last few days
to convince her colleagues
that the energy environment is
an important global issue.
From a political
scientist's point of view,
the missing piece
constitutes very bad news.
And so we have a
responsibility to try
to factor in politics back into
the energy economy environment
mix.
Let me turn now to the
second item for today.
There's a light here that's
going to start blinking
when I should stop.
So whenever it starts
blinking, I will stop.
I'd like to give you some
sense of the global system
today based on the
principle on what you see
depends on how you look at it.
Please take that
seriously, even though this
sounds like a trite
observation because I
will show you some
multiple realities,
the size of those realities
on a global basis.
And you can think of
this as footprints
or as burdens or whatever, but
this is the world out there.
We'll start with the relative
view of the people, the power,
and the pain.
This is the total
world population.
There's a familiar
world map kind
of adjusted a little bit to the
relative demographic statistics
per country.
And this is the same world
map adjusted a little bit
to the same people but warring
from 1945 to two years ago.
People at war, so to speak,
or populations at war.
And this is the same
global map inflated
by percentage of military
spending for the year 2002.
Now the only purpose
of all this--
there's a whole bunch of
that we will share with you--
is that these are
conventional indicators.
And hey, this is
the way life is.
But then we have some even
maybe conventional but seriously
unpleasant situations
that if we can actually
locate those landmines
and if we can seriously
think about reconstructing those
areas in which the landmines
were there, have
been put in place,
what's the energy
strategy for doing this?
The past has shown us that we
usually build what we already
know how to build, which is
built into inefficiencies--
what happens next.
This is who died
violently, and this
is who died through self-death.
Now suicide is the word.
In the social sciences,
we think of suicide
as a reliable indicator
of unhappiness.
This is at the individual level.
But what happens
if we try to talk
about aggregate unhappiness?
And I'm not trying to draw
too much into this distortion.
This is telling us that if we
violate the ecological fallacy,
which is you can generalize from
the individual to the state,
then we have sources of real
unhappiness in the globe
that we haven't seriously
paid attention to.
The next two slides are the
missing pieces of the migration
that I showed you
a long time ago.
And this is people leaving.
Where are they leaving from?
And they're not
leaving voluntarily.
Now remember when
people cross borders,
they come with their
claims and their demands
on infrastructure,
including energy.
So this is where they have
left from not voluntarily--
because of conflict
and violence.
And again, refugees are not part
of the migration statistics.
It's a different category.
And this is where they go to.
The interesting thing about
this other than the most obvious
is the mutual
concentration in an area
which is Europe and Africa
and the rest of the globe.
Well, we know
we're going to have
under normal circumstances,
not refugee-related massive
investments in infrastructure.
Now, the good news--
views of the world in
terms of human creativity
using patents as an
example and internet usage
indicating from my point of
view the ability for individuals
to participate or to
express themselves.
This is patents granted in 2002.
Is there anything
odd about this map?
Does anything strike you as not
the way we would wish it to be?
There was a question earlier
to President Hockfield
about the extent to which we
consider economic issues when
we think about energy
and energy futures.
We do consider them very much.
Before seeing this
particular map,
I had not expected
the dual balloon view.
I'd expect the
concentration to be
much more on the Western side.
And this is internet
users in 2002.
For me, internet users represent
voicing of individuals.
It's the first time
in human history
that an individual
unit, a statistic,
as opposed to an aggregate,
is able to articulate anything
on in any communication
venue on a global scale.
So that's the other side
of the world that we live--
another view other views of
the world that we live in.
A couple more things before
we move on to the political
realities-- think of these
are just descriptors--
the past wealth, the
carbon emissions,
and the future wealth.
This is the wealth of the
globe at the beginning
of the last century.
This is the wealth,
the carbon emissions,
and you see that's
not too difficult.
And this is the wealth
of the globe in 2015.
There's a big green
chunk in there
that was not anticipated before.
Now let's turn to
the real thing,
which is the political
realities, the politics
of energy for the 21st century.
And only thing I will do is
highlight structural features--
the parameters of the game
rather than policy features.
What should we tweak
here and there?
Again, this is what we
now have to live with.
We have more global volatility.
It goes without saying.
We have more sovereign states.
We have more
intergovernmental agencies.
We have more multinational
corporations.
That, I suppose,
is the good news.
But we also have more
non-governmental organizations.
Now the combination
of all these mores
creates a very interesting
political algorithm.
Just a quick view of
each one of those--
the more nation-states,
more civil wars,
and more terrorist rebel groups
in the very recent years.
We call this volatility.
This is the creation
of new states
now think about new states as
every one of those entities
has a vote--
positive, negative, or neutral--
and is sitting at the table
and is actually sitting
at all environment
and all energy-related
negotiation tables.
The larger the number of
individual decision entities,
states, the more
complicated things become,
but this is the
world we live in.
The UN membership
more, the establishment
of leading intergovernmental
organization,
which is bureaucracies at
the global level, more.
And then we have
more multinationals.
And here the figures
speak for themselves.
Let me draw your attention
to the very last bullet,
and that is 50 of
the world's largest--
50th largest economies
are not countries.
They're corporations.
So the economic size is massive.
The political vote can
never be direct, of course,
because corporations,
they'll sit around
the table as individual voters.
They sit around the table
as part of the lobbyists
or the supporters of
individual states.
And the difficulty
there, of course,
is that the global corporations
have global interests that
don't always map to those
of the individual states.
And here is the really, really
newcomer of structural features
of the world, and that is the
growth in non-governmental
organizations--
otherwise known as
NGOs, otherwise known
as interest groups
that are organized
to do good things in
the world, to do better
in the world, et cetera.
Two points are relevant here.
One is they have actually
been able to secure
a seat at the table
at the political table
and international forums, not
voting, but they are there.
And they make their views known.
Second important thing
that's really important
is that these are entities
without accountability.
There is no mechanism
that has yet
been invented to make these
entities accountable to anyone,
really, except themselves if
they have an accountability
mechanism.
So we consider that important
and interesting because it's
an example of incomplete
institutional design.
It's very unlikely that the
situation will remain as it is.
But because the
voices are so strong
and they're very, very
strong and very organized,
on both sides of
the energy issues--
whatever the sides might be--
that these are very
well worth watching.
So what does all this mean?
And what does all this mean if
we think about global energy
strategies and global energy
situations for the remainder
of the century in the
context of the priorities
of the nation and the priorities
from a scientific point
of view?
What it means is
really quite simple.
It's started to blink, so
I have to speed it up here.
There are more stakes
and more stakeholders--
please notice I didn't
use the word stock
and stockholder's interests--
more constraints on
decision, more possibilities
for spoilers, and
then, of course,
more limits on the use of force.
There are some
things that we really
can't use the traditional
instruments of violence that
has been so effective
in the past.
So the bottom line is
that we are looking for--
there's more need of the
politics of consensus.
Politics, by definition, is
about competing, competition,
and about conflict.
Now we're trying to figure
out how to push the envelope
on the collaboration and on
the proverbial win-win-win-win
situations.
That is part of
actually thinking
about new strategies
for negotiation,
assuming we have developed
the national consensus on what
we need to do.
Now is not clear to me that we
have a national consensus yet,
but let's assume
we'll have one soon.
We then have to
move that consensus
and try to influence
the global arena.
If it's the politics
of consensus,
that means let's
talk, and there are
some barriers to being able to
speak clearly for this reason.
And that is that on the one
hand, we're moving to a world
where individuals and peoples
begin to matter, that peoples
are not always
willing to be funneled
through their
national governments.
Every one of the governments,
of course, speaks English,
so this is not relevant to them.
But on the other hand,
we've got to figure out
how to reduce the
gap in communication
and in the disconnects in
our respective communications
of which language is one of
the more pervasive barriers.
So conclusion-- I
have two conclusions.
So conclusion number one
is restating the obvious.
I think, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Be very fast.
The second bullet, we have
to pay an inheritance tax.
We've got this legacy.
Let's pay the tax.
Not let's pay-- we're
going to have to.
And we can minimize the pain.
This is my last slide.
So allow me to take it slowly,
because it's rather important.
We've learned a couple
of things from the legacy
of the 20th century wait, okay.
One is context matters,
et cetera, et cetera.
The one that is most serious--
this is my last
sentence, I promise--
the most serious from
an analytical point
of view, challenging from
an analytical point of view,
most challenging and one that
we're trying to deal with
is the third bullet.
And that is to take into
account the time factor.
Time is money.
We know that.
And time marches along somehow.
We know that too.
But what else this time do?
Now it's your turn to
answer the question.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHOUCRI: I do?
Oh.
So apparently, there
is time for questions.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
I believe that we
are in an emergency situation
as we speak right now.
And I define emergency as
when you see the bullet coming
at you, and you know
there's not enough time
to get out of the way.
In particular, I think the
emergency is one of oil.
I've seen recent articles
in the Wall Street Journal
where there was a clarion cry by
several accounts for large oil
companies.
I've spoken privately
with someone
who was on the board of a major
oil company in the last five
years.
There was also a
public statement
made by the CEO of Total S.A.
That there was no possible way
that we can meet the
projected growth and the oil
requirements of the world.
And I believe that we're looking
at a permanent and growing
worldwide oil shortage in
approximately 5 to 10 years,
and we're out of time where
changing out the transportation
fleet takes about 20 years.
So my questions
to you are, first,
is this recognized in
the energy staff of MIT?
Two, given that
this would be true,
what are the implications
for the economy
and political structure and
stability of the United States?
And three, what are the
implications for world
war in a situation like this?
The answer to the first question
is is, yes, it's recognized,
and that's a very
important footnote here.
For those of us that were
members of the faculty in 1973
when the first oil crisis--
the first big one--
the Institute's response was
the establishment of the Energy
Lab, if you recall.
Several of us were talking
the other day about the very
unfortunate deja vu image.
We've gone through this before.
If we didn't know that
this was 2000-something,
it could have been
1973 with respect
to oil in a very narrow way.
That particular
crisis disappeared.
As you remember, the decade of
the '80s, things went smoother.
So I would say it's a little
worse than you have described
it because, now, not only do
we have this oil business--
and there hasn't been any
good news on the oil front
for quite a while--
I didn't show you the real scary
part, which is the refinery.
The refineries are operating
almost at full capacity,
and that as they say
in very good news
just pushing on
the infrastructure.
In addition to this, we
have all this other stuff
that's come along, which is
the CO2 stuff, which was not
part of the 1973 oil crisis.
We didn't recognize
it at the time.
With respect to world
war, the core of what I do
is conflict and violence.
Why do people go to war?
And when is this going
to happen, et cetera?
So I expect war any time.
I think I that I do not
want to get into this.
I also teach Middle
East politics,
so you can imagine how--
that's it?
MODERATOR: One more over here.
AUDIENCE: I have one.
Am I on?
CHOUCRI: Okay.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHOUCRI: Well, Iraq's
oil is not flowing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it's the whole region--
Iraq, Iran [INAUDIBLE]
CHOUCRI: Let me say
the premise first.
It's not clear to me that the US
presence is a major contributor
to stability in the region
because the instabilities don't
come from governments anymore.
They come from groups, people,
terrorist, good guy, whatever.
The real instability
is happening
because governments are losing
control over their people--
so with or without
the US troops there.
And unless the US is going
to try, which is impossible,
my colleagues tell me,
because of the constraints,
the limits on manpower in
the military to really police
the entire region.
So the bottom line is
it's not clear to me
whether the physical presence
contributes to stability
or fuels instability.
AUDIENCE: Hi, can you hear me?
CHOUCRI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Okay, I
thought you said
a couple of really good things,
and I want to repeat them.
CHOUCRI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And then I have
sort of a general concern,
but I won't really name that.
And I'm going to ask
a specific question.
So one of the big
factors in my life--
and maybe it sounds
like in yours--
is to help people talk
better about politics.
Because as you mentioned, people
find it very uncomfortable.
And unless you're
a professional,
people almost don't
want to do it.
So you're one of our few.
I'm on the other side.
I'm not a professional.
I never want to be.
But I want to talk
about it, so I want
to learn how to talk about it.
So the other thing you
said that I really liked
was that it was on this slide
about the world languages.
And you said-- let me find
the quote-- here it is.
There are some barriers
to speaking clearly.
And I think that sentence to me
encapsulates the entire problem
of talking about politics.
There are so many
barriers to clarity.
And in that vein,
I'd like to ask
for clarity on your
numerous pictures
that showed the pretty
graphics of the world shapes.
And I didn't know what
the size of the country
meant as opposed to
like, for example,
it seems like there are borders.
They're always there
and no matter what.
And the colors also change.
And I wasn't sure what color was
what because it didn't clearly
represent a rainbow to me.
CHOUCRI: Yeah.
MODERATOR: That was
the last question.
CHOUCRI: First of
all, I apologize
for not being clear at the very
beginning about those maps.
This is a representation.
These were distortions of
the territory-based maps
that we're familiar with.
Pick up any atlas, you see
the political boundaries.
So it's just readjusting
the boundaries
by the relative size
of the US population
relative to the
total population.
The colors were not meant to
be happy colors, rainbows.
It just were just those colors.
And about talking
about politics,
I only do it in class.
I can't give you any advice.
And my last statement is this.
It's in the form of a PR for
the research that we're doing,
but it's rather
interesting or important.
And that is the global system
for sustainable development
is a knowledge
networking system,
distributed system that
is mirror sited in China
and currently going to be
mirror sited in Lebanon.
It operates in four
languages, two of which
are not really your
common normal languages
of everyday discourse
in the United States--
Arabic and Chinese, English,
of course, and the fourth
is French.
And given the fact that the
world's population is not
English speaking,
we're very pleased
and very proud to be able
to operate in at least two
of the major
non-Western languages
where we know there
are lots of people
that don't speak English.
So if you have a chance, take
a look at the GSSD website
because this is a
typical MIT product.
And what is not typical
is that it comes out
of the social
sciences as opposed
to the rest of the campus.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HOCHMAN: Well, I'd
like to say that I'm
thrilled and privileged to
introduce Professor John
Fernandez.
Part of the reason
I'm thrilled is
because as of about
8:00 PM last night,
he was trapped in the
New Orleans airport.
And despite FAA computer crashes
and tropical weather systems,
he managed to make
his way here today.
So I really am thrilled to be
able to introduce Professor
John Fernandez.
An associate professor
of building technology
in the MIT department of
architecture and a practicing
architect, Professor
Fernandez primarily
focuses his research on
the materials of buildings
and the design of assemblies
for resource efficient
built environment.
Lately, his interests have
been centered on the emerging
opportunities for linking
design, urban planning,
and building technologies in
the creation of green cities
and resilient communities.
This morning,
Professor Fernandez
will address the
growing challenge
of limited global resources amid
an ever-expanding urban world.
Please join me in welcoming
Professor John Fernandez.
[APPLAUSE]
FERNANDEZ: Can you hear me?
Mic's on.
I have to do a little
A/V shift here.
The A/V person
asked me to do this.
I think I can do it.
Although I'm MIT faculty, so
it might take a little bit.
There we go.
Okay, yes, I was in
New Orleans yesterday.
I flew in this morning.
I did have a beautiful
black suit picked out.
It's at home.
I do bike into work
every day, so I
rummaged through my office.
And I found this.
So please bear with me.
I'm thrilled to be here.
I am part of the
department of architecture.
We're a little department at
MIT just across the street.
I'm class of '85 from that
department and back as faculty.
Thank you to Ira, to the Tech
Day committee for inviting me.
I just want to take a minute
and thank the class of 1957,
not just because
it is your 50th,
but because that class was
very generous in supporting
my work the last few years as
a career development professor.
So I really very
much appreciate that.
Clearly, the topic of resources
and energy in particular
is the topic of the day.
It's going to be the topic
of generations to come.
That's for certain.
I'm trained as an architect, so
my expertise is in buildings.
But in the last few years,
I've spent quite a lot of time
on linking resources and design
and engineering of buildings.
If you want to pick one
of Professor Deutsch's
has strategies for dealing
with the energy issue,
my talk would probably fall
under moderate demand--
how to design better buildings
and how to design them in a way
that people reduce their demand.
In last several
years, I've actually
spent quite a bit of time with
a variety of organizations,
including architectural design
firms, various companies, now
several cities.
And I'm coming to the conclusion
that the momentum is there.
It's not political momentum.
It is grassroots momentum for
a better built environment.
I like organized presentations.
I'm a bit compulsive.
This is organized
around three questions.
Okay, first, it is
really important
to be very clear about what the
built environment is, what am I
talking about, and I'll
delve into that second
is how much of our
global resources
are consumed by
that environment,
not only in operation, but also
in construction and demolition.
And given what we know from
answers from the first two
questions, should
we even change?
Do we need to change?
Will change in the
built environment
make much of a difference?
I'm going to throw out
a lot of information,
lots of pretty pictures.
I am an architect.
So I'm hoping that you
can make your own decision
about whether the built
environment usually left out
of the discussion on energy--
I should say often left out--
should be part of
the core discussion
of energy and global
climate change issues.
So let's see what we can
get out of this effort.
I have 40 minutes.
I'm hitting a real brick wall
in terms of the schedule,
and that's lunch at one o'clock.
So I'll make sure to try to
get you to your lunch on time.
Okay, so what's the
built environment?
Let's revert to
some fundamentals.
The built environment
very directly
stated is that which
provides shelter,
always has provided shelter.
It's one of three very
basic fundamental needs
of the human species, food
and water being the other two.
There are very, very
few places on Earth
where you can live
without shelter.
The critical role of
shelters hasn't changed,
but the diversity of
shelters, buildings
has changed as our activities
have evolved and become
much, much more diverse.
So here this is actually a
photograph of a new building
here in Boston, the Institute
of Contemporary Arts.
When shelter was
first invented, there
was no such thing as
contemporary arts.
So the diversity of activities
has really exploded,
and that's why the
built environment
looks the way it does today.
Our first understanding
of the world
was very much about
where you could live
and where you couldn't,
what was habitable,
and what was inhabitable.
And creating shelter
that allowed migration
and settlement was the beginning
of the making of the largest,
longest lasting most
material intensive,
and now one of the most
energy intensive things
we've ever made as a species.
And that's what I want to
call the built environment.
This is actually an image
from a colleague of mine Ann
Spurn in architecture.
Over time, very slowly at first,
domestication agriculture--
we all know this story--
along with a building arts led
to the creation of settlements.
And this has not
abated ever since.
Huge proportions of our
extracted material and energy
resources have been devoted
to the making of buildings,
settlements, roads, dams--
all the infrastructure
that we depend on so that
today, this is what we have.
This is the built environment.
This could be many
different cities.
Concrete is the
primary material used
to build the built environment.
It's actually the second most
consumed material in the world,
second only to water by people.
And actually, concrete also--
I don't have this
in my script here--
but concrete contributes some
somewhere between 6% and 8%
of all CO2 emissions--
so 6% to 8% of
total CO2 emissions.
Let me give you some facts on
where we are with the built
environment on a global scale.
So within the last year,
this past year or 18 months,
or two years--
it depends on who
you're talking to--
the global urban population
has surpassed 50%.
Now 50% of the world
lives in cities,
and that will
continue to increase.
Projections say
pretty much forever,
but that's predicting
the future.
I won't be here in 75 years.
So it's an easy
prediction to make.
A majority of that
urban population's
within easy reach of the coast.
The fastest growing
urban populations by far
are located in Asia and
Africa, and China now
astoundingly accounts for
one half of all construction
in the world.
As a result, there are
significant resource issues
to consider.
80% of CO2 emissions is
caused directly or indirectly
by people living in cities.
75% of wood consumption is
used for construction and fuel
in cities, and 60%
of water withdrawals
also occurs to serve
the residents of cities.
This is an urban world that
is also a very poor world,
and we should take note--
although I won't go into
that discussion today--
that that's a really
significant issue
because that level of affluence
will most likely increase.
And that's a big
factor that we will
have to take in terms
of resource consumption
in the future cities.
On the homefront in the
US, the built environment
amounts to 130 million
residential buildings.
We add approximately 1.8
million residents annually
depending on the economy, six
million commercial buildings,
170,000 new buildings
of this type annually.
And we demolish about
50,000 buildings a year--
commercial buildings a
year-- that again also varies
significantly with the economy.
The bad news is that
cities tend to promote
more intense
resource consumption
on a per capita basis.
It's partly due because
the logistics of housing
large numbers of people,
getting them to work,
having places for them to
work, industries located
around cities, but
also the affluence
that's gained from living in
cities and working in cities
and shopping in cities.
Take, for example, the
increasing popularity
of air conditioners in
cities around the world.
Now I want to pause
here for a second
and say that I'm part of a group
called the building technology
program.
And the people standing
behind me for now
are Marilyn Anderson, John
Ochsendorf, Les Norford,
and Leon Glicksman.
We do all of this work together.
And these air
conditioning numbers
are something that
Leon has talked
about for quite some time,
and I've taken them to heart.
In China, more than 87 out
of 100 urban households
now own an air conditioner
compared to 24 out of 102,000
seven years ago.
As a result, China is now
the world's largest producer
of air conditioners, and India
is following closely behind.
Now air conditioning
is something
that a great deal of
the rest of the world
is looking forward to.
This is happening now
and gaining momentum
and will continue to happen most
furiously in expanding cities.
The image I'm showing here
is actually a per capita
electricity consumption.
Just notice the uptick--
sorry-- the uptick in two-year
period in Shanghai, 1995, 1997,
massive urbanization
liberalization of the housing
market, increasing number
of air conditioners,
and general affluence
increasing during that time.
It's a 76% increase in
electrical consumption
in that city over
a two-year period.
Shanghai, by the way, for
the past several years--
looks like next year
might be the same--
has added more building
space than exists
in all of Manhattan.
That's every year.
So let's do something here.
Let's generalize these ideas.
Let's kind of
bring them together
because there is a
really interesting--
I spent a lot of time
these past few years
with industrial
ecologists who referred
to the work of
natural ecologists.
I'll leave it there in terms
of the whole ecology debate
and is that a science or not.
But there is a
very useful concept
that I've used in
my teaching before.
It's the concept of succession,
of the idea that there
is a dynamic process by which
one ecosystem transforms
into another over time and seems
to be done and seems to happen
often in sort of step function.
A rainforest will
transform into a savanna
will transform into
a desert depending
on a climactic changes
and other factors.
One result of succession
is that the profile
of resource consumption
for that location
changes dramatically as it goes
from one kind of environment
to another.
We can actually
apply this to cities,
especially rapidly urbanizing
urban centers around the world.
And this is one
of my own graphs.
This comes from research
on Chinese cities,
a paper I wrote recently
published in the journal
Industrial Ecology on a
massive urbanization of China.
Basically, I think you can
break it down into three phases,
especially as I said,
massively urbanizing, rapidly
urbanizing cities.
The first phase is
additions to stock,
and that is an overwhelmingly
material intensive phase.
The second is a
stabilization of that stock.
So you're not building as much.
It's becoming denser-- maybe
geographical limits of the city
you're hitting--
and it's tons of fun.
So maybe not adding as much.
You're adding quite a lot.
And then the third phase is
the incremental densification.
The third phase is actually
an energy intensive phase
because once you've
added all the stock,
the energy consumed
by that stock--
stock, I mean buildings--
increases dramatically.
And as those buildings
live over time
and they're renovated
and upgraded
and more and more amenities
are inserted into them,
the energy profile
of these cities
changes so that this
curve, the material curve,
goes up and then goes down.
So, for example, this is
Shanghai few years ago.
This is maybe
Manhattan or Chicago,
and down here, this is Paris.
You don't see a
lot of demolition
in the center of Paris.
You don't see a lot
of new buildings.
So it's stabilized.
What is important is
to notice that there's
a change in the nature of
the resource consumption.
And so right now, all
of these Asian cities
that are growing
rapidly are in here.
We have yet to see this
part of the curve--
the big energy uptick.
So that is what we're facing.
Now consider the fact,
as I stated before,
that 50% of the world--
more than 3 billion people--
now live in cities, and the
world's population curve
is headed for something like
9 to 10 billion, 20, 40, 50.
If the global urban
population increases
to a very conservative 60%--
it will more likely be
somewhere in the 70s--
at least 5 and
1/2 billion people
will eventually be living
in these future cities.
That's 2 and 1/2
billion more people
in cities than today
consuming materials
and energy at urban rates,
not at the rural rate
that many of them are
now or would have been
without massive urbanization.
So this is what I mean by
the built environment--
snapshot of today, a
little bit of the future.
Let's go to question two.
How much of our global
resources is consumed?
I've touched a little bit
on a few consumption issues,
but let me be a little
bit more specific.
Let's start with the US.
Let's start with the US
construction industry.
Construction industry
is this vast messy thing
of 220,000 separate businesses.
The construction
industry is composed
of that many
separate businesses.
Most of them 1,
2, 3 person firms.
That represents more than
$600 billion in annual revenue
and employs roughly
2 million people.
Notably, this
industry fragmented
as it is into hundreds
of thousands of companies
has historically lagged very far
behind other large industries
in its investment for
research and development.
You asked the question,
why are buildings
built the same way today as
they were 50, 75 years ago?
Well, the industry
spends about 1/10
on research and development
as any other comparably sized
or any other large
industry, really,
even mid-sized industry.
Let's go to the energy
consumption of that building
stock in the US now.
The built stock is produced
by this industry is really
one of the--
again, I mentioned that
not always mentioned
consumer of primary energy.
It does account for
40% of primary energy
use residential and
commercial office buildings
also 60% to 70%.
And now I use that range
because now I'm talking
about developed countries.
It's fairly consistent
throughout electricity
consumption, 60 of 70%.
The figure of the
40% increases to 48%
if one includes the energy
used in manufacture of building
materials and construction.
Operating buildings contributes
over 38% now closely correlated
to electrical consumption
38% of carbon emissions
of the United States, 38%.
These numbers are consistent
across the developed world
with some notable exceptions.
Now in the developing
world, energy consumption
devoted to the built environment
is a difficult number
to get at--
hard to get good
data and though there
are a number of
studies to be done.
But we can note
a couple of facts
that outline the future
of energy consumption
in the next couple of decades.
And using the OECD
country designations,
in 2015, non-OECD countries
will surpass the OECD
group in their overall energy
consumption, 2015, eight years.
Between now and 2030.
Non-OECD countries will
account for 3/4 of the increase
in energy consumption.
That's Asia, Africa, others.
And by that year, their
energy consumption
will exceed that
of the OECD by 34%.
Let's take one
component, only one.
I don't have time to go through
heating and cooling and all
the other, but let's
just take one--
again, one that's
not often mentioned
and that is the
energy and lighting.
19% of global electricity use
is devoted to lighting alone--
almost 20%.
I love to show this image with
this sort of sobering fact
before it.
Believe me, it gets more
positive a little later.
I love to show this image below.
I mean, above that
fact because this
is a design of Santiago
Calatrava in Milwaukee Art
Museum, and it's a wholly daylit
space as part of the main hall.
In fact, photograph
of MIT undergraduate
David Fox, who just graduated
a couple of years ago.
Okay, let's also talk about
construction materials.
There's huge material
flows associated
with the built environment.
In fact, a study showed that
70% by weight of all material
flows through most developed
industrialized countries
is devoted to construction.
20% to 30% of the entire
societal waste stream
stems from construction and
demolition waste or nearly 60%
of total nonindustrial waste.
Of this construction and
demolition waste stream,
48% is a result of demolition,
44% result of renovation,
with the remainder
being new construction.
Today, in the States,
we're recovering
approximately 20% to 30%--
depending on the year--
of construction and
demolition waste.
I know you can't see the thing.
That's a million tons.
This is year.
This is construction.
I can't even read it myself.
Industrial and is that
agriculture is at the bottom?
Yeah, okay, from
what I remember.
I mean, you can also look at a
per capita material consumption
in the United States, and these
are kind of amusing graphic
here.
3.6 million pounds of
minerals, metals and fuels
are consumed by every
American in their lifetime.
A huge bulk of that
is construction.
The movement on all that
material costs a lot of energy.
Let's talk just a little
bit more about materials
because materials is
kind of my thing also--
spent a good few years studying
the materials of construction.
Looking at the material flows
for construction and material
flows in society generally has
led to some landmark studies
recently.
Colleague of mine--
well, at Yale--
Tom [INAUDIBLE],,
he's in the school
forestry and the environment has
done a whole series of studies
on the material
flow of the existing
stocks of primary metals, and
he has shown rather conclusively
that a third of that is
left in the ground in very
low-grade ores.
A third is in circulation
in buildings like this
and automobiles,
industrial equipment.
And a third has
been lost forever
in that process dissipated
to the environment.
Why is this important
or useful to know?
Well, we're slowly approaching
not limits to growth,
but actually, the
realization that some
of the best locations, some of
the richest locations for some
of the more important
materials we have
are not in this kind of place.
This is a copper mine.
It's just that the mine
tailings that you see
from the air, an aerial photo.
But actually, copper
concentrations
are now starting to
be richest in cities.
This is a graph of
actually Beijing.
And each one of these bars is
not a proposed super skyscraper
but the concentration
of copper in that city.
Let's remember a very
prescient, poignant, in fact,
quote of Jane
Jacobs, "our cities
are the minds of the future."
Let me tell you my own
personal experience,
not only in New
Orleans specifically,
but in other cities.
There's a funny thing
that's happened recently.
There's a recent
emergence of what's
called midnight plumbers,
and these are in primarily--
they're starting to show up in
inner city housing complexes
mostly from Baltimore
to New Orleans.
And what they are,
as you can imagine,
is they are people who
are stripping the plumbing
from unoccupied or lightly
occupied or temporarily vacant
apartments.
And I read an article recently
the New York Times, which
has had this interesting fact.
The landlord had said that he
had noticed this was happening,
and he had a specific number.
He said, when 20
pounds of copper
equals or exceeds the
minimum wage for one day,
you start seeing this
stuff showing up.
I don't want to talk
about limits of growth--
although you can ask
me questions about it--
but I do want to talk about
the shifting of the location
and the accessibility
to important materials
for society, but also for the
built environment, generally.
Now this brings up an
issue about the way
we treat our buildings
because it is very clear
that until very recently,
the only measure of value
for our buildings has
been a financial measure.
And it's a real
estate instrument.
It is on a ledger as
an abstract thing.
It is not necessarily
considered a physical thing.
I wish you could hear all
the cheers of the crowd
here coming out of my laptop.
But these buildings
have been treated
as essentially things that can
be moved around the chessboard.
Well, I think we're
hitting the time when
the up and coming professionals
designers, architects,
engineers, are starting
to see that that's not
such an easy game to play
any longer, especially
with our infrastructure.
This was, by the way, was
the demolition of the Seattle
kingdom, and it was
an amazing building.
It was actually the
longest thin shell concrete
span in the world.
Its cousin, the pantheon,
has lasted for a long time.
The Seattle kingdom
lasted 25 years.
When it was only
25 years almost,
demolished just out of college.
And when you read
about green buildings,
one of the first things
you'll read about
is green materials,
recycled materials,
low-energy materials.
Well, let's be real.
Actually, in terms of societal
consumption of materials,
it's pretty clear
we're not being
any more renewable
than we used to be--
so say, 1950 proportion.
So this is renewable
versus non-renewable
versus renewable
materials, proportions
of which societal consumption.
So this includes other things
besides the built environment
but as we know, 70% by
weight material flow.
So the built environment
plays a large role here.
That's my disclaimer.
In 1950, we were there.
Today, we're not
doing any better.
We're doing worse 95%
non-renewable to 5%.
So this is a trend
that we really
do have to think about,
especially when we factor
in the energy that it takes
to push all of these materials
around.
Okay, I want to round
out question two.
How am I doing on time?
I got 33 minutes.
With a composite measure that,
I'm sure you are all very fond.
I'm sure some of you are better
informed about this than I am.
But the ecological footprint--
a composite measure
developed the latest version
developed by [INAUDIBLE]
They keep a website
at globalfootprintnetwork.org.
The ecological
footprint is a measure
of the global societal
demands versus supply
of biologically productive
land for everything
that we do from
agriculture to construction
to manufacturer
building materials.
A couple of recent or
relatively recent thresholds--
one particularly ominous
one that we crossed--
and you can certainly
debate the way
they calculate the ecological
biocapacity of the earth.
But in the late
1980s, we crossed
this is number of planet Earths.
So the biocapacity of one planet
Earth is outlined right there.
This is years, 60, 70, 80, 90.
and this is a huge physical
accounting exercise
that the group goes
through, and they've
been doing for its
peer-reviewed massive effort.
In the late '80s,
they determined
that we crossed the
threshold in going
from on an annual
basis demanding more
than the supply could give us.
That doesn't mean that
you can't supply all
of that demand in the future.
It just means that,
well, we're digging
into the natural
capital, basically.
And you dig into natural
capital far enough,
and you can endanger
certain ecologies.
Like an old-growth
forest, you log it enough,
and it's no longer a
biodiverse environment
it's something else.
In 1960, the population of
the world was 3 billion,
2,006.1, actually.
Interesting thing is, while
you double it and you get more.
Of this the ecological
footprint was 0.5 Earth's.
That's 1.2.
And the difference
between those two,
if one would expect that
maybe a 0.5 at six billion
would be one.
Well, the difference
between them
is increased the
increase in affluence
and our increasing ability to
extract the resources that we
want so that right now,
we're at 1.2 Earths
and scheduled to
continue rising.
This feeds into the discussions
about tipping points
on various ecologies
around the world.
Okay, so that's the
built environment
the filtered way that I see
it for today in 45 minutes.
The third question,
let's address that.
Should we change the future?
Well, I'm already
convinced because I'm
one of four points on a
slide and Professor Deutsch's
presentation that,
yeah, we should
because we're talking
about moderating demand,
essentially and designing
better so that demand
doesn't increase.
There's a lot I could say about
using the ecological footprint
to answer this question.
Let me suggest a
direct answer for now.
Today and tomorrow
and into the future,
this is something
that you can do.
Look at the
buildings around you,
including this one
buildings that you live
and work in the
buildings that you visit.
For most of those buildings
in the United States,
you can decrease its energy
consumption by 10% to 15%
with a buyback time
of about five years--
no question about it.
You can do it tomorrow.
Those are efficiency savings--
better insulation
and better windows.
The way fuel prices are going--
heating, fuel prices
and electricity--
it is possible to do that
within a five-year payback.
This can best be done--
I'm also not going to talk about
solar because this can best be
done with an
integrated approach,
accessing renewable energy
sources-- solar, micro,
wind turbines and
other technologies--
But it should be coupled with
efficiency, conserving energy,
be more efficient in our
use of the energy that's
already provided to
us for our buildings.
Let me give you another answer
to this question, which I think
should be a kind of a rule
of thumb for green building
people around the world.
And that is it's probably
best to increase the energy
efficiency in existing
buildings in the developed world
because we have a lot of
stock, and we have a lot
of very underperforming stock.
Still build a lot but we
certainly don't build this
as much or will build as
much as the developing world.
And that leads to the
second point, which
is it's very
important to increase
the efficiencies in
the way new buildings
are brought on online
in developing countries.
Couple those two
together and you've
got a very powerful strategy
for moderating demand globally
for the built environment.
You know what?
I spend a lot of
time with students.
I teach a lot.
I just got tenured
thanks to class of '57,
and I want to say you
guys really helped out.
[APPLAUSE]
So actually, what I want to
bring in here are students.
I want to answer the question
from the student point of view
because I see the student
body has been extraordinarily
powerful force in all of this.
I want to answer the question
through Tom Weathers.
Tom, if you're watching, hello.
Tom is a recently
graduated just yesterday
master of architecture
student MIT,
and he dedicated his thesis--
full three semesters of
prethesis research and then
actually writing it to
investigating the possibilities
for using the existing material
flow here on campus, the MIT
campus, particularly
underutilized
the valuable waste
stream materials
in the design and construction
of a low-energy building.
His question was, is there
enough flow around us
that we can maybe capture some
of it and make a good building?
He produced as a
result of this study
as far as I know, the first
comprehensive material flow
analysis of the MIT community.
And then he analyzed
it for the potential
for using new buildings.
So the idea is so waste
that's floating out there,
capture it and make
a new building--
sounds very academic in some
ways kind of unseemly, I guess.
But in Lexington,
just north of here,
there is a house that was built
of the detritus-- previously
the detritus [INAUDIBLE] most
of the primary structural
elements, many of the very
high embodied energy materials
in this building.
A lot of the exterior
envelope materials
were directly captured
from that flow.
And you can look at the
big dig and say, well,
that was a huge material flow.
Well, some of that was
captured a tiny, tiny little
less than a drop was
captured for this building,
but it's a really
interesting approach
to the way a
designer would think
about what are the resources
that I have at my disposal.
Another student I
want to mention here
is Lucille [INAUDIBLE].
Lucille is a current master
of architecture student.
They both gave me
permission to show these.
They're happy with it.
And she's also
very much a person
who thinks that we
should change the future.
Her project of last term
in the design studio
brought into focus the need to
consider architectural form as
shaped by the potential offered
by solar radiation by the sun--
an old topic.
But so much of our
architectural form
has nothing to do with the sun.
So much of our architectural
form is oriented to what?
The street-- fly
anywhere to look
at the little curving
streets and where how
are the houses looking.
They follow the streets.
So her idea is that there
needs to be design, technology,
and planning that
directly proposes
that the configuration
of buildings
should follow potential
for solar heat
gains, solar shading,
not a new idea.
In fact, let's remember
that this approach really
had its origins--
one of its origins--
here in the solar houses
at MIT in the 1930s--
way back in the 1930s.
In fact, in 1938, the Committee
on Solar Energy Utilization
at MIT was set up.
And for the next 50
years, until 1988,
a series of six experimental
and prototypical houses
were built here at MIT and
served very much as the seeds
to things like this.
This is the Passive
House Institute.
This is material from
the Passive House
Institute in Germany.
A person there named
Wolfgang Feist paid attention
to the MIT work,
and he spent a lot
of time perfecting a combination
of super insulated shell
with heat recovery.
The breath that I breathe,
the heat that I'm producing
can be recovered and
then preheat incoming air
from the outside,
high performance
windows and a systematic
elimination of thermal bridges
between the inside
and the outside
the cold outside in the
warm inside, for example.
And he produced a
design, a passive house,
and it's a really
important approach
to residential architecture.
For the United States, 68%
percent of our US housing stock
is still single family
housing, and the median age
of our US housing
stock is 27 years,
which means that we're a
country of new housing.
And this kind of
approach still has
relevance-- we can still apply.
10,000 of these houses
have been built.
This is not a pipe dream.
This is not the Wolfgang
[INAUDIBLE] one office.
Okay, so these MIT people
have done all of this.
Now I want to make it real.
I want to make it
happen in the world.
And he did--
10,000 of them built in Germany.
The Passive Institute
has expanded its range
to include other building
types, multifamily, multiunit
residential buildings, apartment
houses, schools, office
buildings, community centers.
The passive house-- let
me be very direct clear.
There's been a whole
series of conferences
on the passive
house-- lots and lots
of data taken over 10 years.
I think there have been seven
passive house conferences.
I know that probably
wrong, but it's close.
This is typical.
So the kilowatt hour
per meter squared here--
a passive house-- welded
built passive house--
but perfectly well verified
and standard passive house
construction will lead to an
85% to 90% reduction in energy.
This is in Germany
and northern Europe.
There is a group
that I'm actually
talking to quite a lot
who's got a demonstration
project in Uxbridge.
They're bringing they've
actually licensed
the passive House technology.
They're bringing it to Oxbridge.
They're going to build
a building there.
MIT hopefully we'll
be monitoring it
so that the passive house
can become commercialized
in this country.
So in my opinion and in
light of the first kind
of sobering 2/3 of
this presentation,
I think all of this
last few slides
is very good news because the
built environment does offer
an opportunity to
improve our resource
efficiency while
revisiting again,
the value that we place
on architectural spaces
in the public realm.
This is actually
one of my buildings.
I had to throw it up there.
It is actually before I had any
of these thoughts in my mind,
before I came to MIT.
This is actually in
addition to the law school
at Columbia University.
They needed public space,
and it's south-oriented.
And these aluminum fins and
that [INAUDIBLE] glass, which
is a kind of veiled glass.
So the enamel baked
onto the glass
is basically designed for
solar heat in winter and none
in the summer-- very,
very straightforward idea.
Another kind of project which
really, my project showed
before really did
come out of the work
of the MIT solar houses and
idea of solar architecture.
Other projects have come out
of that, other technologies,
including aerogels, super
insulating silica foam
materials having
upwards of 10 to 20
times the thermal resistance of
typical insulating materials.
And another building,
okay, so this
is solar house taken to an
extreme commercial office
building.
We see them all over the
place, glass buildings.
This building shades itself.
It shields itself.
It's very straightforward,
very simple idea.
We don't see a lot
of this around so
that's why I'm an optimist.
I think there are very
straightforward, simple
actually quite beautiful
solutions to moderating demand.
We do need material research,
fundamental material research.
And I've done some assemblies
research, depending
on the materials scientists.
We do need inexpensive
and high performance
thermal insulation materials.
We still do, inexpensive.
Responsive, spectrally
selective coatings for glass
desiccate materials of all
kinds to moderate humidity
when you bring in outside air.
Self-healing vapor
and air barriers--
I think we're on the cusp
of a number of breakthroughs
there and more.
We need more
fundamental research
on the materials for buildings.
And we're seeing some of this.
We're seeing the more
inventive, maybe not as
risk averse, or maybe very
successful architects.
So they can take some
risks doing these things
on a big scale.
These are shots from Lorenzo
piano's New York Times
building in Times Square.
If you haven't seen it here
in New York City, go visit.
It's a building with a
huge solar shade on it.
It's an amazing building.
These are ceramic tubes
around the entire thing.
It's got a veil to temper that
solar heat gain, still entirely
glass building, and this is the
Hearst building, 57th Street
and Eighth, I think.
And that, again, has
very sophisticated
specially selected glass
as part of its wall system.
Also there are very
exotic materials
that we really do need
to spend some effort on,
and these are things Ike
phase change materials--
so high thermal matured
materials that absorb or are
give off heat as
they change state.
These are extremely
useful materials.
All of your seats could have
phase change materials in them,
and we could lower the
temperature of this room
all right so because the thermal
exchange would be at the user.
Oops, sorry-- at the
user where it matters,
not up there in
that volume where
it doesn't matter as much.
Solid state lighting is
a huge important field
to reduce that artificial
lighting because there
is a paper that is
published March 30, 2007,
so it's fairly recent.
It's on the materials for
aesthetic, energy efficient,
and self-diagnostic buildings.
But in addition to
materials, we also
need some decision-making
tools for the designer.
This is a material
selector software.
The mechanical engineers have
had material selection software
for a few decades now.
The aero-astro certainly
have and the architects
and the engineers, the stewards
of 70% of that material
throughput have not.
So with Mike Ashby at the
University of Cambridge
in the UK, he and I developed
this as a tool, an initial tool
to give architects
an idea of how
to make rational decisions
between materials
that they're considering.
This is just actually showing
you that production energy
or embodied energy,
which you can't read,
versus CO2 emission
very tightly correlated.
So a body then of CO2 material
and CO2 that's emitted.
That's a tightly correlated
pairing of properties.
And I haven't talked about
the production of power
in buildings-- so building
integrated renewable
energies, photovoltaics.
I'm not even showing
photovoltaics.
Photovoltaics is a
whole 'nother topic,
and I think it is
extraordinarily important
and will be part of the
solution for moderating demand.
But I also wanted to show you
some maybe not so commonly seen
images of a building.
Actually, these are
renderings of a building
in Chicago recently built--
I think completed by
the previously big
corporate architect Helmut Jahn.
And that's a micro
turbine on the top
of it runs the length
of the building
and purportedly is supposed
to be delivering the lighting
energy for low-income
housing, by the way.
Okay, so the huge
elephant in the room
is global climate change, which
I haven't really spoken about.
I'll just spend just
a couple of slides.
It's 51.
I have like three minutes.
there's
A topic that I'd like to
introduce, not get into today
but tell you that it is the
umbrella topic for efficiency.
As you see an image of Hurricane
Maria heading for New Orleans.
This talk of efficiency
gains is really
set under the uncertainty
of vast changes
to ecological
anthropogenic systems
due to global climate change.
If energy efficiencies brought
to the built environment
do not account for the
uncertainty of global climate
change, we run the risk
of being overwhelmed
by producing
buildings that rapidly
become inappropriate
in their locations
and for their occupants.
An emerging set
of priorities then
is starting to really
change the way a growing
group of designers--
I already mentioned
this-- designers,
industrial ecologists,
engineers, planners,
urban planners are thinking
about the new future city,
the green city.
That is, if we can accept
the notion that the built
environment is one very
large complex system,
then it would be
prudent to explore
the ways in which that
system can be designed
within an enhanced capacity
for adaptation and resilience
and ability to respond
to shocks to the system.
So I'll leave you just
with two current designs
that I'm working on.
One is a kind of
a modest proposal.
It's for a house.
We're calling it
the MIT float house.
I am privileged to be involved
in a number of projects
in New Orleans.
Believe me, the
next two years are
going to be really
interesting in New Orleans.
A lot is happening, not only
just because of the hurricanes
but a lot of them.
You go to any restaurant
there, and no one
in the room, no one
in the restaurant
had been there pre-Katrina.
And they're all PhDs and
engineers, and I mean,
it's an interesting place.
This house is designed--
it proposes an alternative
to relying on a centralized
levee-based flood
protection system--
very simple.
The house floats
when the city floods.
The city will flood.
People are building now
houses slab on grade--
in other words, the concrete
at grade, building up,
and it will flood.
So okay, so but the
implication here
is it goes far beyond
just this design.
And that is, is
there an opportunity
to rethink the way we actually
deploy infrastructure.
And we actually design
architecture not
to depend on these large
centralized systems,
even for power generation.
For example, what if we were to
develop ways in which we could
distribute using microgrids
renewable energy community
organized and owned systems
for power generation?
That would simultaneously
lead to a reduction in demand.
And anyone that owns the
thing that's producing energy
is going to maintain it.
They're going to want to know
how much energy [INAUDIBLE]..
They have the knowledge of what
it is that they're getting at.
You just write a check to the
energy company for that power
plant, which is 70 miles away.
Well, there's kind of
a different engagement
dynamic going on there.
So but it also then says
that that community could
be more resilient to shocks.
So when it does
flood, this house
elevates because it's got a
chassis of a buoyant material.
It's held in place
because you've
got paragraphs, which that
make for a purely vertical rise
and keep it in place.
So it deals with
lateral movement.
And these hydraulic
columns fill with water.
So these fill with water.
The flood goes away.
Water goes away.
This is not a fiction.
The floodwaters are gone.
The house is still up because
the thing you also want to do
is to protect the
house from looting.
So it's a lot harder to
loot this house then.
Okay, so the owner comes back,
or the community comes back
and slowly lowers each one.
The second proposal, I
actually want to talk about--
I'm a designer.
I throw out these ideas.
Let's see what sticks.
Both of these are real projects.
I'm talking to a developer on
the house I showed you before.
And this project
is also in play,
and that is the idea which I
just mentioned of a zero-energy
community that has an
emergency water system,
on-site storm retention basins,
thermal storage reservoir,
phase change materials that
can circulate throughout all
the buildings,
microwind turbines,
building integrated
photovoltaics,
and emergency power source
served by the micro grid
and local flood surge break--
all within the goal of a
diminished carbon footprint.
This is the idea of a resilient
semi-autonomous community
that is now green.
So these are some ideas that
I'm working on recently.
I think this is a
direction that--
at least for me in my work
in building technologies--
is where I think
we can contribute
to moderating demand.
Let me just read my
last paragraph here.
The idea that resilience
and adaptability
can be design priorities
initiates a whole new era
for architecture that
incorporates as central core
priorities are
evolving understanding
of global resource consumption
and global climate exchange.
It will certainly be a
challenge to fully assume
this approach within
a business that
has always resisted any change.
But I'm quite optimistic
that real change,
productive and
positive, is coming.
I think it can be a
critical part of that too.
There's an enormous
wealth of momentum here.
I'm not entirely counting
on political momentum,
political will, counting on
a lot of other kinds of will.
So if you hire an architect,
as opposed to what Bucky Fuller
asked the architect, how much
does your wall building weigh
years and years ago-- though
it's a decent question to ask,
by the way--
you should ask
your architect, how
is the person or firm going to
produce a strategy for reducing
the resource consumption of
that architectural proposal.
I hope personally that
the answer that you get
comes from one of
my former students
because then I can
assured that it can be
both effective and beautiful.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I can take five minutes
worth of questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: First, I'd like to say
that I was really disappointed
up until your talk
because I thought
I was at the other
place down the river
because it was all blabber
and very little reality.
And you brought a lot of
reality to this thing.
No, I mean,
seriously because you
can do all kinds of studies
and projections and everything,
but you're building real things.
And you're dealing
with real things.
And that's very important
because if we knew the answers,
we'd be at Foxwoods, not here.
FERNANDEZ: Can I
respond, actually?
AUDIENCE: It's a
preamble to the question.
FERNANDEZ: Yeah, but I did say
that my piece was one of four
was moderating demand.
My opinion is
moderating demand will
be an extraordinarily small
portion of what will contribute
to the stabilization of CO2
levels in the atmosphere
and all that.
So that's one really small part.
All the other abstract work and
large infrastructure systems,
all that--
I am totally on board
with all of that
having to be talked
about in the way
that Professor Deutsch
talked about it, which
is that if I say it's
possible, somebody doesn't say,
oh, I can do it tomorrow.
But we need to figure
out how to do it.
AUDIENCE: Well, first of all,
as the head of NASA said,
why are we saying that this is
the climate that we necessarily
want to maintain?
Why don't we just
see perhaps that we
can adapt to the climate
as we have always
adapted to the climate?
When it got cold, we put our
clothing on, built shelter.
When it got warm, we moved,
whatever the case may be.
So the point is,
and the second thing
is it's really, really bad
for people in a place like MIT
to deny reality in the sense
that they say CO2 is the most
important greenhouse gas.
FERNANDEZ: I'm sorry.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, any
gas with those number
of atoms that present
will do essentially,
the same thing in
water vapor, which
is far more prevalent
in the atmosphere
is much more important
as a greenhouse gas.
But let's leave that out there.
The question is this.
If you foresee the global
drive going the way it is--
and that's, again,
a projection--
with decreasing population
growth rates in the developed
countries, how do
we take advantage
of our expertise
and our knowledge
in the built
environment and transfer
that in a productive
way to the third world,
fourth world whatever where the
big growth is going to occur.
How do we do it productive?
FERNANDEZ: So there is a
very, very quick answer
because I want to get one
other question in here.
The answer to your question
is that is happening.
There are literally
hundreds of people
thinking exactly
about that question
and doing different things.
For example one quick example
is LEAD in the United States.
So you know LEAD is Leadership
in Energy and Environmental
Design.
It'd build a rating system--
I think that's correct--
build a rating system
that is intended
to be used by architects
to certify that they've
done as much as they
can to reduce resource
consumption of their building.
It's a rating system.
It's not an actual
monitoring of that,
but it is a tool that's now
being transferred to countries
all over the world
or the attempt
is to transfer it to
countries all over the world
so that at least there's a
benchmark that architects can
work with.
So that's just very, very quick.
But rest assured there's
very good awareness.
And there's huge effort
to transfer what we
know to the developing world.
And by the way, the
developing world
is more politically
progressive than many
of the countries in
the developed world,
I think might be.
The one last question.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
percentage of reduction
of energy consumption from
simply planting deciduous
trees like on the southwest,
east sides of the home?
FERNANDEZ: Yeah, great question.
And that is to hit
solar heat gain.
So when you reduce
solar heat gain--
and it varies tremendously
with climate--
but in a climate
like this, solar heat
gain on the west side, for
example, late afternoon,
the building's already warm.
I'm not going to
give you a number,
but there is significant
savings that you
can have by making sure
that that building does not
heat up late in the
afternoon, and you
continue to need some
kind of air conditioning.
But that's a good point.
Okay, actually, the
point is being stressed
that lunch is on the tables.
Thank you.
Enjoy, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]